vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir les hommages
du mali ibrahim boubacar keita l'ancien
président décédé cette semaine avait été
renversé par les militaires il ya un an
et demi les obsèques nationales ont lieu
dans un camp militaire à bamako nous
serons en direct avec notre envoyé
spécial cyril payen dès le début de ce
journal
la grippe aviaire détecté au burkina
faso une catastrophe en perspective pour
la filière avicole au pays du poulet
bicyclette reportage à suivre auprès des
exploitants
relâche ce vendredi à la can pas de
match les joueurs se reposent avant les
huitièmes dé finale qui débute ce
dimanche joue ce soir sur une légende
locale le cotonsport de garoua
c'est le club mythique du pays reportage
à suez
au nouveau ce journal par les obsèques
nationales de ibrahim boubacar keita
l'ancien président est mort ce dimanche
chez lui à l'âge de 76 ans il avait été
déposé par un coup d'état militaire il
ya 18 mois la junte a tenu à organiser
des funérailles dans un camp militaire
et nombreux sont ceux qui sont qui ont
tenu à faire le déplacement pour rendre
un dernier hommage à celui qui a dirigé
le pays pendant six ans est coupée
il a tout faire
pour que les hôtes et de la transition
puisse bénéficier
tous les accompagnements possibles
pour le peuple du mali pour le mali pour
la politique du livre que l'entreprise
pour notre pays après devoir quitter le
pouvoir il voyait la prestation qui se
veulent assez de temps que c'est
compliqué ça deale attriste beaucoup
avec ses chagrins dans le coeur un pays
qu'il aimait
les sanctions contenues allez allons
retrouver notre envoyé spécial cyril
payen en direct de bamako cyril vous
avez assisté à ses funérailles
organisées par une junte qui a elle-même
renverser le président ib cas le mali on
le sait connaît une transition politique
tendu les militaires ont-ils réussi à la
faire oublier le temps d'une cérémonie
en tout cas c'était évidemment vous avez
raison de le dire le message assez clair
à un grande cérémonie qu'on a pu suivre
effectivement deux concorde nationale
d'hymne national avec à une succession
des loges funéraire par les compagnons
de route du président défunt certains de
ses anciens ministres sa famille qui ont
rappelé évidemment la qualité d'homme
d'état du président défunt qui dans une
cérémonie plus privé chez lui a été
inhumé alia quelques instants ce soir
ici même à bamako quelques jours après
avoir succombé à 76 ans dimanche dernier
et puis vous lisez aussi justement près
de deux ans après avoir été déposé par
ses hommes mal et même somme paraderont
qui au plus haut sommet de l'état
puisque le premier ministre cheikh el ma
et gars étaient représentés le colonel
simi ghaith al président du gouvernement
de transition a été empêchée n'était pas
là ce matin mais le l'ensemble du corps
diplomatique et bien il était et étaient
présents deux mille invités triés sur le
volet donc le message était très très
clair encore une fois un moment solennel
de concorde pour ce dernier voyage du
président défunt qui eût été et puis
pour le dire très franchement il y avait
depuis quelques jours beaucoup de
rumeurs qui bruissaient à bamako sur la
présence de délégations étrangères et
pourquoi pas exceptionnellement malgré
les sanctions très dures qui frappe le
pays et qui asphyxie le pays depuis près
de deux semaines maintenant qu'ils ont
été passées par la cedeao l'association
économique d'afrique de l'ouest on
pensait qu'il y aurait peut-être un
volet politique à ses obsèques et
peut-être une reprise de dialogue pour
tenter de désenclaver le pays alors ce
sont cette question c'est raté puisqu'il
n'y avait aucun membre de deux
délégations étrangères à part peut-être
et ses notables le ministre les affaires
étrangères de guinée qui a fait le
déplacement donc c'est ont tourné
évidemment la page ib cas c'était un
hommage national maintenant on sait bien
et on le voit bien avec un ballet
diplomatique important que le
gouvernement de transition tente de
renouer le dialogue avec les pays
voisins tentent de de parler pour encore
une fois des angles a fait ce pays qui
commence à être asphyxiées dont le sait
les prochaines semaines vont être
difficiles pour aux questions pour les
questions politiques sociales et
économiques pour des millions de maliens
merci beaucoup cyril faille entre pour
toutes ces explications en direct depuis
bamako
on en vient à cet accident dramatique
survenu au ghana ce jeudi les autorités
ont ouvert une enquête pour déterminer
les circonstances et responsabilité de
l'explosion d'un camion qui a fait au
moins 13 morts mais selon les premiers
éléments l'accident aurait pu causer
beaucoup plus de dommages sur les sites
bon nous en dit plus
dans la petite ville d'à piety au ghana
l'explosion d'un camion a soufflé des
dizaines de maisons des centaines
d'autres ont perdu leur toit des portes
et des murs ce cratère et le lieu précis
de la détonation le bilan est lourd et
il aurait pu l'être encore davantage si
le chauffeur du camion n'avait pas agi
aussi vite
lorsque son camion plein d'explosifs et
percuté il alerte tout le voisinage du
danger imminent au moment de l'explosion
la plupart des habitants sont déjà
parties ont lieu sur owni la police a
aidé le chauffeur ils ont alerté les
habitants ils se sont notamment rendus
dans l'école locale pour évacuer les
enfants loin de là ce n'est
une enquête criminelle est encore en
cours pour comprendre les circonstances
de cette détonation le camion qui
transportait des explosifs pour une mine
locale aurait été percutée par une moto
un transformateur situé en bord de route
aurait peut-être aussi était percuté
un désastre majeur nous a frappés c'est
pour cela que le président hu nana akufo
addo m'a demandé de venir ici avec une
délégation pour voir comment nous
pouvons aider les habitants
le gouvernement a promis de prendre en
charge les frais médicaux des nombreux
blessés les habitants qui ont perdu leur
maison ont été abrités dans des écoles
avant que les autorités ne leur trouve
un logement
au nigeria des djihadistes ont tué deux
personnes et enlevé 20 enfants dont une
près 13 jeunes filles la taxe est
produit dans l'état de borno a pillé mis
non loin de chine boc village qui reste
associé à l'enlèvement en 2014 de plus
de 270 jeunes filles dont la moitié
d'entre elles sont toujours portées
disparues
dix mois après son décès l'opposant
congolais guy brice parfait kolélas a
été enterré aujourd'hui au bourget en
france en présence de son épouse ses
enfants et de quelques proches la figure
politique de l'opposition est décédé en
mars 2021 lendemain d'élections
présidentielles à brazzavile un dernier
hommage lui a été rendu à son domicile
notre correspondante au rosie piotte qui
étaient sur place et nous explique les
raisons du délai de l'unima sion
c'est au terme d'une bataille judiciaire
longue de dix mois que l'opposant
congolais guy brice parfait kolélas a
été finalement inhumé aujourd'hui en
france la bataille qui opposait la femme
de l'opposant et une partie de sa
famille biologique porté sur les causes
réelles de sa mort pour certains pas
comment les surnommer n'est pas décédé
de suite du convive 19 comme annoncé
officiellement ils demandaient une
troisième protoxyde mais c'est
finalement la veuve qui a obtenu gain de
cause un soulagement pour les militants
et les autres sympathisants et opposants
qui étaient nombreux aujourd'hui à être
venus dire au revoir à guy brice parfait
kolélas après dix mois d'attenté nous
pouvons que nous ravir de cette décision
car aujourd'hui
notre président va
voir au moins se reposer en attendant de
retrouver la terre de ses ancêtres
peut-être à une date ultérieure je crois
que chacun de nous s'en souviendra
surtout avec son message est très fort
pour le changement qu'il a légué au
congo qu'il a laissé à tous les hommes
politiques parce qu'il il a voulu fait
comprendre aux congolais qu'il s'est
battu mais il souhaite que ce combat
arrive à la victoire à savoir le
changement et l'alternance démocratique
lui d achiou qui le parti de guy brice
parfait kolélas prévoit d'organiser une
grande messe de requiem en son honneur
mais le parti de l'opposant est
désormais divisé et des nombreux
observateurs craignent l'implosion
des cas de grippe aviaire ont été
détectés au burkina faso près de 500
mille volailles ont été tuées et un
million trois cent mille poules et ont
été perdus huff ont été perdus depuis
fin décembre une catastrophe aux pays du
pays du poulet bicyclette et puis démis
commence à avoir un impact économique
chez les éleveurs et vendeurs de poulets
kalidou sy
il est 6 heures et comme tous les matins
bibata arrive sur son lieu de travail
avant de se rendre à l'université
cette étudiante en économie démarre sa
journée avec sa passion l'aviculture
lancé en 2019 son élevage ne compte pas
moins de 500 poulets mais depuis
l'annnonce du retour de l'épidémie de
grippe aviaire le 14 janvier les clients
se montrent frileux bibata s'inquiète
pour son commerce
est
là depuis la mort je n'ai même pas
parce que j'ai beaucoup lu que je dois
je dois vendre y a pas marché et cela je
laime je lai mûri mois du combat je suis
en train de perdre quoi c'est une perte
pour moi salle
même son de cloche chez ce vendeur de
poulet grillé qui constate une
inhabituelle diminution de la clientèle
depuis le début de l'année
ici à ouagadougou nous n'avons pas
constaté de volailles contaminées par la
grippe aviaire avait depuis que le
ministre a parlé de l'apparition de la
maladie nous ne faisons plus de recettes
par contre dans mon élevage en campagne
plus de 1000 poulets sont morts depuis
descendre la d'actifs du côté des
autorités on veut rassurer les
consommateurs et on assure que l'état
burkinabè fera son possible pour aider
les commerçants en difficulté
ok la grippe avait tué une personne il
faudrait que la personne ait vécu
pendant longtemps avec des oiseaux
malades tout ce qui roule ont perdu et
que été récensés litres va trouver des
moyens pour pouvoir soit allégé les
crédits soient allégées de mécanismes
d'importation des matières premières
pour pouvoir réaliser
l'activité de colis d aide bienvenue
dans un pays où le poulet fait office de
patrimoine national pour preuve en 2021
les autorités burkinabè ont lancé un
processus de labellisation du célèbre
pour les bicyclettes pour valoriser le
poulet local qui subit la concurrence de
volée importés et un point de la can
2000 21 pas de match ce vendredi mais le
programme des huitièmes de finale qui
commence dimanche alors deux affiches
burkina faso gabon et nigeria tunisie
on suivra ça sur france 24 mais cette
relâche nous donne l'occasion de faire
un focus sur le football camerounais on
vous propose de découvrir une légende
locale le cotonsport de garoua un club
phare du nord du pays qui le plus titré
du pays champion du cameroun champion's
league africaine mais aussi vainqueur de
la confédération de la caf mais quel est
le secret ce club qui a réussi à fonder
formé tant de champions reportage de
richmond amina tony magi stéphanois
comme tous les matins l'équipe première
de coton sport de garoua est en pleine
séance d'entraînement dans son centre ah
mais non je blague non sous les ordres
de solibad ou à du bois car les
champions en titre du cameroun pour
fielder préparation malgré l'attitude de
laquelle somme
faisons là une
autre championnat donc la can le moment
le devais même pas nous perturber étant
donné que juste après cette can là le 13
nous jouons déjà une compétition
africaine jean contre al masri de jeep
s'illustrer une nouvelle fois sur la
scène continentale l'ambition renouvelle
et de coton sport en 20 ans le club
phare de la région du nord a réussi
l'exploit de devenir le plus titré de
l'histoire du foot camerounais avec ces
championnats et six coupes nationales
des trophées entreposés au siège du club
que nous montre ici fièrement fernand
sadou le président bien ici nous sommes
dans la salle de réunion où nous avons
mis
presque tous nos distinction honorifique
que nous avons eues depuis la création
du club et puis 1986 ici là vous avez
une image qui illustre deux grands
joueurs de coton sport aboubakar vincent
et salli edgard
vaka vincent qui actuellement continue
dans les lions indomptables
l'attaquant vedette de la sélection
camerounaise et actuel meilleur buteur
de la can fait partie du vivier des
talents formés par coton sport douze
années plus tard dans cet hôtel où
séjournent les joueurs camerounais il
tient à exprimer sa reconnaissance
voir autant ce procès
simple pour commencer pour précisément
se lancer kim affirme aussi d'essayer
kim avait mis les siens à valenciennes
parce que c'est un club qui m'a aussi
beaucoup marqué
ma carrière
boubacar symbole de la réussite de coton
sport de garoua et de la formation
camerounaise à garoua où il a touché ses
premiers ballons ses exploits
retentissants sont plus que jamais une
source d'inspiration pour les jeunes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis en particulier
en ce2 mumba à bab el oued en passant
par san giorgio a créé maintenant rester
avec nous car l'actualité continue sur
france 24
[Musique]
oui